we have new information on what happened
to more than 2,000 children forcibly
separated from their parents under the
trump administration zero-tolerance
border policy policy for undocumented
immigrants a senior official tells CBS
News about 500 children have been
reunited with their families since May
it's unclear how many of them are being
detained with their families or remain
in the u.s. under intense public
pressure President Trump signed an
executive order temporarily ending the
separation of families the
administration says it's now exploring a
plan to use US military bases to house
up to 20,000 detained immigrant children
who arrived in the US alone David Beck
knows at a Children's Shelter in McAllen
Texas where the first lady made a
surprise visit yesterday David it was a
surprise good morning Gail good morning
when we stood here yesterday we didn't
know she was going to be showing up a
few hours later but the first lady says
she came here to New Hope shelter
because she wanted to help speed up the
reunification process CBS News has
learned that three children staying here
at the shelter have already been
reunited with their parents about 55
remain look there are roughly 2,000
children who have been separated from
their moms and dads sent many places
around the country and we've asked a lot
of questions about how they got there
where are they and all the US government
will tell us is we assure you we are
tracking every one of them the bottom
line is how and when are they going to
be reunited
this was the first time this Guatemalan
mother held her son in more than six
weeks identified only as Delia
she told the intercept that her
five-year-old now refuses to leave her
side Delia and her son crossed the Rio
Grande River on an inner tube and were
detained May seventh for entering
illegally they were finally reunited
last week Delia was released after an
asylum officer deemed that her claims of
an abusive relationship back home were
credible
despite zero tolerance she was not
charged with entering the country
illegally
prosecutors have the discretion what
charges to bring and which ones not to
bring Texas civil rights attorney
Efrain olivera's says he was in federal
court Wednesday in McAllen when
prosecutors decided not to charge 17
fathers who allegedly crossed the border
illegally with their children and were
separated
prosecutors say their decision was not
related to the separation issue the men
are still in custody now awaiting a
deportation hearing the parents were
very confused but their main concern was
the children where are my children when
am I gonna see them again and
unfortunately I did not have an answer
for them their children were probably
sent to shelters like new hope for
so-called unaccompanied children during
her visit here yesterday First Lady
Melania Trump was told that three
children have already been released to
their families fifty-five remained how
many times they speak with their
relatives or families per week for
example Kurt sanski oversees the shelter
if a parent were to get out of custody
could they come here to pick up their
child and that would all depend on on
the specific laws and the specific
situation of each child and our case
managers would work walk through that
so most undocumented immigrants who are
prosecuted under the president zero
tolerance policy are charged with
illegal entry into this country if
they're a first-time offender it is a
misdemeanor crime and nor what usually
happens is they get credit for time
served and they pay
fine sometimes as cheap as $10 all right
David thank you so much